car fans rejoice as one of gaming's best
racing franchises is back with forza
horizon 5. the horizon series is known
for its more arcadey take on the forza
formula with gorgeous open worlds to
explore and a seemingly endless amount
to do 5 looks to be no different and is
the perfect time for new players to jump
in thanks to his day 1 availability on
xbox game pass here is everything to
know about forza horizon 5 and if you
enjoyed this video make sure to give us
a like and sub it really helps out
returning to develop is playground games
who yes are working on that new fable
but thankfully are large enough to
continue working on the horizon series
now horizon games are known for and
doing an amazing job of featuring
different parts of the world with each
title in three it was australia four was
the rainy countryside of great britain
and with five we're going to the lush
and varied mexico i say varied because
the game will feature 11 biomes
representing the different climates and
environments of the country we've got
canyon tropical coast rocky coast
jungle swamp sand desert living desert
volcano arid hills farmland and urban
that's a lot so much in fact that mexico
is the largest horizon map to date being
50 bigger than horizon 4. the team has
said they've taken great care to do
justice to the setting and stress that
they spent a lot of effort making sure
they don't play into any mexican
stereotypes this means working with a
mexican scriptwriter and a cultural
consultant creative director mike brown
said we want this to be a game that when
a mexican plays it they feel like it's
been made with care and love and i
really feel like we've taken this very
seriously to help mexico feel alive is
the return of seasons first introduced
in horizon 4. but this time things have
been anted up further with dynamic
weather weather is now local to a
specific region and you can see a storm
off in the distance and yes chase after
it if you wish i pray this eventually
leads to a twister themed dlc where i
get to live out the fantasy of being
bill paxton chasing after tornadoes
weather will be adapted based on both
the current season and the biome you are
in creating a much larger variety of
potential driving conditions but let's
talk about what you'll be doing in
mexico campaign mode returns this time
called horizon adventure your goal is to
get into the hall of fame which you do
by earning accolades there are a lot of
them with the idea being that you don't
have to earn all of them and instead can
focus on the types of challenges and
objectives you enjoyed the most as a
result horizon adventure is a lot less
rigid than previous horizon campaigns
there are 6 festivals in horizon 5 and
after the game's introduction you can
tackle them in any order you want this
is all part of the game's goal of giving
players more freedom as you explore the
map you'll naturally come across arcade
mini games the devs have compared these
to destiny's public events an arcade
event will spawn on the map you drive
over to it and will be grouped up with
other players online there are 12
different challenges and mini games they
are collaborative in nature such as
pinata pop where you work together to
destroy as many pinatas as you can or
bullseye where you need to jump off
ramps to hit the floating target the
horizon series has been pushing new
types of custom user created modes and
content over the years three introduced
blueprints and bucket list challenges
four added super seventh and five is
looking to take things even further with
event labs this is a new tool that lets
you create your own races and game mode
in many ways it looks to be forza's take
on halo's forge mode we've seen a small
sample of what event labs can do such as
this game mode where you have to run
into giant bowling pins but it won't be
until it's in the hands of the community
that its full potential will be revealed
the game's competitive multiplayer mode
previously called team adventure in
horizon 4 is now called horizon open the
change in name is to reflect the mode's
more accessible nature and removal of
skill based matchmaking don't worry that
doesn't mean there isn't any challenge
but playground games has expressed that
they just want the mode to be more fun
and casual for people to enjoy there
will be four playlists available in
horizon open open racing which offers a
variety of racing from street to cross
country open drifting for drift
challenges playground games for pvp
modes like flag rush and king of the
hill and finally returning in horizon
open is the eliminator forza's take on
battle royale the mode was added
post-release in horizon 4 and quickly
became the game's most played online
activity
horizon 5 has gotten an extra year of
development time compared to previous
entries and playground games has talked
about how this has allowed them to tweak
the driving to create a better
experience for example they've rebuilt
the way both suspension and brakes work
to feel more authentic and realistic
while realistic may sound like it's more
difficult in reality playground games
has said that this change has actually
made it more accessible and fun to drive
they've also talked about how they've
improved the experience when using a
racing wheel which should be great news
for all you die hards out there with
insane racing setups that i desperately
wish i had the space for and speaking of
die hards i know some of you love seeing
what real cars are available in these
games after all these are gorgeous cars
we can never have in real life but at
the very least we get to live that dream
in forza horizon 5's cover cars are the
mercedes amg 1 and the 2021 ford bronco
badlands other brand new cars to the
series include the 2020 toyota supra the
mark 1 ford escort the ford f-450 super
duty the porsche mccann rally raid and
the porsche taycan turbo s to name a few
on the customization end playground has
promised over 100 new rims 100 visual
upgrade parts thousands of performance
upgrades and the much requested ability
to paint your brake calipers there's
also the new audible upgrades which can
change the sounds of your car such as
the intake or exhaust character
customization is getting a much needed
boost you are still stuck with a
selection of preset faces but you can
now change your hair and hair color add
prosthetics pick your pronouns and voice
on top of having a greater pool of
clothing and accessories to work with
forza horizon 5 will be the first entry
on the new generation of consoles series
owners can expect a greater level of
detail in the environments and increase
draw distances thanks to the power of
the new systems ray tracing is supported
but only in forza vista the series mode
that lets you admire your cars up close
bit of a bummer but that doesn't mean
the game won't look gorgeous the rest of
the time the game features a new
volumetric lighting system and the
developers have talked about how they
have captured thousands of different
skybox photos at a whopping 12k
resolution so at the very least the
horizon
it's going to look pretty good series x
players can enjoy horizon 5 at 30 fps 4k
on quality mode and 60 fps 1080p on
performance mode meanwhile the series s
will run at 30 fps 1080p on quality mode
with a 60fps performance option
available as well the game will still be
available on xbox one systems as well as
pc we haven't seen how the game looks
and runs on xbox ones yet so maybe wait
and see before you try those versions
the great news is if you have xbox game
pass you've got the game available to
you on launch day november 9th but if
you are itching to play it four days
early you can upgrade to the premium
edition for 55 dollars might want to
start that download now though as it is
a whopping 102 gigabytes
yikes but if you don't have game pass or
want to wait and see how the game turns
out before spending all of those
gigabytes on the download make sure to
come back to gamespot for our full
review of forza horizon 5. thanks for
watching
you